Kurt Russell and Goldie Hawn have been  partners for more than 30 years and they  still manage to surprise each other  Goldie took pause to embrace nature on  Monday literally the 71 year old actress  was photographed hugging this giant tree  in Los Angeles while Russell fills their  parking meter  check out his face when he realized what  Goldie was doing the Overboard actress  looked ageless in a casual black tank  short white skirt and flip-flops  meanwhile this 66 year old actor looked  dashing as ever  sporting a pink t-shirt jeans and beige  shoes this isn't the couple's first  hilarious run-in with nature  earlier this month Goldie shared this  video from their morning stroll around a  lake look at the geese  music she captioned the clip I swear  there were geese there and here they are  in July hiking biking and even enjoying  a lakeside picnic  [Music]